nobody likes bailouts the idea that
rotting companies that exploit their
customers their employees the
environment and who knows what else are
able to receive a bailout from taxpayer
money just because the company is
quote-unquote too big to fail is
disgusting the official reasoning for
bailouts is that if these companies were
to collapse hundreds of thousands of
jobs would be lost and the subsequent
economic shock waves would be
catastrophic but maybe that's actually
better than keeping these parasitic
corporations alive
but that's besides the point the point
is that bailouts have a terrible
reputation and for good reason
however there have been a few bailouts
in history that have actually played out
surprisingly well you would think that
this would be most likely to happen with
a small company that's nimble and quick
but this actually happened with the
biggest bailout in history aig
aig was an insurance conglomerate that
was suffering insane losses so the
government came to the rescue with an
appalling at 182 billion dollars the
bailout itself is large enough to be the
world's 60th largest company now i don't
support this bailout but the us
government did end up profiting from the
bailout and that things worked out
surprisingly well
so here's why a company even needed a
182 billion dollar bailout and why the
bailout actually kind of worked
182 billion dollars is an insane amount
of money so how did a company even end
up in such a terrible position well the
answer is half a century worth of
terrible decisions that eventually
caught up aig wasn't always bad though
like most companies aig was started with
good intentions by a man named cornelius
vander starr cornelius was born to a
dutch family living in fort bragg
california in 1892 things started off
good for cornelius when he was a baby
his father had a respectable job as a
railroad engineer and the family was
able to comfortably get by but this
didn't last long as his father would
pass away when cornelius was just 2
years old
this forced the family to take in
borders to get by if you don't know what
this is it's basically converting your
house into a long-term airbnb to earn
money considering this background you
would think that cornelius would play
things safe when it came to his career
but he was always more of a risk taker
he would drop out of uc berkeley after
just one year and would try opening an
ice cream shop this was somewhat
successful but nothing crazy so he would
end up joining the us army near the end
of world war one cornelius never got
deployed but he could feel this urge to
travel and see the world so he would get
a job as a clerk at a japanese office
and move to japan from there he would
travel to shanghai china in 1919 and
this is where he would found aig though
it wasn't called aig at the time
the young company focused on providing
western insurance products to the asian
market which proved to be quite popular
soon enough cornelius had operations
across all of southeast asia along with
the philippines indonesia and malaysia
it wasn't until he had a strong presence
in asia that cornelius even opened an
office in america but even after opening
an american office cornelius didn't
really pursue the american market maybe
he thought it was too competitive his
reasoning was not too clear but
something that was clear was that aig
was phenomenal at attracting customers
in developing countries so naturally
cornelius would turn his attention to
cuba and latin america it wasn't until
world war ii hit that cornelius finally
shifted his focus to america you see it
cornelius saw an opportunity to provide
insurance for military personnel which
turned out to be extremely popular after
the war cornelius would spend his time
expanding across devastated european
countries like france italy germany and
the uk
clearly cornelius was no saint he built
aig on the backs of other people's
hardships first he leveraged people from
underdeveloped countries then he
leveraged military families and finally
he leveraged war streak in europe
cornelius was no doubt an opportunist
but something he wasn't was a fraud when
he was at the helm aig was sounded
financially i mean they literally
survived the great depression but
naturally cornelius couldn't run the
company forever so he would end up
handing the company over to a man named
maurice r greenberg also known as hank
in the 1960s and this marked the
beginning of the end
ever since hank joined aig he only had
one goal which was to impress his
superiors at first this was cornelius
and eventually this would become the
shareholders now trying to impress her
superiors isn't a bad goal per se
but the problem was that hank was
willing to do almost anything and this
was evident from the very beginning when
hank was hired in 1960 he was given the
task of developing an international
accident and health insurance business
but his approach to doing so was
completely different from what we saw
with cornelius much of cornelius's
success could be attributed to his
patients he never forced an opportunity
he was willing to wait years if not
decades for the right opportunity it
doesn't seem like hank was a fan of this
approach though as he far preferred to
create this opportunity and the way he
accomplished this was by leveraging
insurance brokers instead of insurance
agents for most of you guys this
probably sounds like the same thing but
there's a small difference you see
insurance agents are employed by the
insurance company meaning that their
loyalty lies with the company it's in
the agent's best interest to find the
best clients to ensure
insurance brokers on the other hand are
technically supposed to be loyal to the
customer but really the only thing
they're loyal to it is the commission
it's in the broker's best interest to
complete as many transactions as
possible the quality of the transaction
doesn't really matter to them so from
the company's perspective in the long
term it's better to use agents than
brokers because while agents are more
expensive they'll secure higher quality
clients and protect the liquidity of the
firm but hank threw all of this out the
window and went all in on brokers he
figured that even if sales went down the
company would be more profitable thanks
to the small commissions that brokers
charged in the short term this made him
look like a genius as his departments
were more profitable than ever but what
he was really doing was gambling the
financial integrity of the firm for more
revenue and profits and as we go further
along in the story you'll realize that
this was a common trait for aig
at first hank was simply cutting corners
here and there to inflate the company's
profits but eventually he would turn to
full-on accounting fraud in the early
2000s inc orchestrated multiple
fraudulent deals with offshore entities
to make it seem like aig's reserves were
larger than they truly were these deals
also inflated aig's profits by nearly 4
billion
when these activities came to light in
2005 inc would be ousted from aig after
leaving the company for 37 years but the
damage had already been done while hank
had succeeded in growing the company's
market cap from a few hundred million
dollars to a few hundred billion dollars
and made aig the world's largest
entrance company he had also destroyed
the company fundamentally all it would
take is one gust of wind to blow over
this house of cards and that's exactly
what happened in 2008
in the end it was two risky practices
that screwed over aig and these were
credit default swaps and securities
lending credit default swaps are pretty
complex financial instruments but for
our purposes we can just think of them
as a type of insurance if you have home
insurance and something terrible happens
to your home the entrance company would
cover the damages right well it works
the same way with credit default swaps
but instead of insuring your home to
ensure corporate debt for example let's
say gm needs more money to build a new
factory you as a lender are willing to
lend gm this money but you want to make
sure that even if gm can't pay back
their debt you get your money back so
you get insurance on this debt called a
credit default swap this way even if gm
collapses aig will pay you back a
certain percentage or even the entire
loan based on the terms of the swap but
the thing to note is that aig does not
actually have enough money to pay back
all of these swaps it's unlikely that
all of these corporations default at the
same time so aig only has to carry a
portion of the total amount to insure
now this wouldn't be a problem if these
swaps were a small portion of their
portfolio but aig had written swaps on
500 billion dollars worth of assets and
as we now know corporations were
defaulted left and right throughout 2008
meaning that aig had to start paying out
massive checks but this wasn't even what
screwed them over what screwed them over
was a downgrade in their credit rating
on september 15 2008. this downgrade
meant that aig had to put up
significantly more collateral to back up
their credit default swaps collateral
they didn't have i think you can guess
what happened next
it wasn't just credit default swaps that
were screwing over the company either
they were also getting burned with
securities lending as an insurance
company aig owned millions of shares of
stocks bonds options futures variable
annuities and basically every other
security you can think of now aig could
have just kept these securities to
themselves but aig wasn't satisfied with
the returns that the securities could
offer by themselves so they decided to
lend out these securities in return for
interest this is a pretty common
practice amongst financial institutions
and it wouldn't have been that bad if
aig stopped right here but they would of
course take it to even the next level
you see when someone borrows a security
from aig aside from paying interest on
the security they also have to give aig
cash collateral the borrower can pay
back the security at any time and ask
for their cash back so it's an aig's
best interest to keep the cash
collateral as liquid as possible but aig
decided that it would be a great idea to
invest his cash into subprime mortgages
when the financial crisis hit a lot of
aig's borrowers were trying to raise
cash for the recession so they paid back
their securities and asked ig for their
cash collateral back but you know what
this cash was invested in subprime
mortgages which um completely collapsed
so yeah it was bad
at this point it was just a matter of
time until aig needed a bailout
aig would go on to post some of the
worst corporate quarters known to
mankind on this channel we often discuss
market cap losses but the losses that
we're about to discuss are not market
cap losses they're cash losses in q3 of
2008 aig would report a net loss of 24.5
billion dollars which was the eighth
worst corporate quarter ever and that
wasn't the worst of it in q4 of 2008 aig
would lose 61.7 billion dollars which is
the worst court recorder ever reported
to this day with these types of losses
even a 182 billion dollar bailout would
only last a few quarters and that's why
they got such a massive bailout the
bailout didn't come for free though the
us government got a 79.9 stake in the
company for the first 85 billion dollars
and aig had to pay back the remaining
bailout with interest fortunately this
was enough money to sustain their losses
and get them through the recession which
is what aig really needed i mean it's
not like aig was the next radio shack or
sears their business model was still
profitable the problem was that it only
worked in bull markets so they just had
to get through the bear market and
that's exactly what the government
helped them do
as the economy recovered so did aig's
bottom line and they would become
profitable again in late 2010 this
allowed them to pay off the bailout with
interest at the same time the treasury
was slowly selling off aig stock on the
market and by the time everything was
said and done it the u.s actually ended
up profiting 22.7 billion dollars
meanwhile things that worked out pretty
well for aig as well they've downsized
significantly since their peak but
they're still worth over 40 billion
dollars so they're still pretty big
considering this happy ending some have
argued that bailouts don't have to be
bad if done correctly but in the end i
think it still comes down to a consent
issue with such bailouts the government
is essentially making everyday americans
a shareholder in these garbage companies
which is something the taxpayers never
consented to sometimes if bailouts can
work out like with aig
but by definition bailouts are handed
out to companies with the most liquidity
risk so more times than not it's not
gonna work out but even if it did i'm
still not a fan of bailouts given that
they're not approved by the people that
are funding it also i think it's
probably best if such companies go under
it anyway but that's just what i think
do you think aig should have been bailed
out comment that down below
also drop a like if you're not a fan of
bailouts either and of course consider
checking out our discord community to
suggest future video ideas and consider
subscribing to more questions logically
answered but until then i'm hari and
i'll see you guys on the next one
you